Yeah.
Since it's going to take a minute for this to start up,
I'll show you a demonstration here.
Um,
it's a way to make tea.
Yeah.
It's a really clever device called a sox Sullen extractor,
and it,
it was invented in order to extract stuff from like bark or leaves or something
like that.
Something that's very insoluble.
So you could imagine to do it like tea,
you put it in a filter paper,
poor solvent through it.
Some of it dissolves,
it goes on through,
and then you have to concentrate the solution.
Okay.
But there's another way to do it,
which is to use this thing here.
Now,
how are we doing
and see if I can get the,
uh,
to show up here.
Okay.
So the idea is that the problem with that is if the stuff isn't very soluble,
it takes an enormous amount of solvent to get it out.
So what was invented by this man?
Socks lit
and I'm having trouble here.
It's his audience,
right.
Dot.
Uh,
why is this not on?
Okay.
Oh,
somebody unplugged it.
Sorry for the confusion here.
Technically challenged today.
There we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
So
Huh?
Oh,
we have,
here is a flask down below that's going to have the solvent and not very much
solvent.
Okay.
Uh,
am I good?
I like that.
Okay,
so we're going to boil the solvent.
It's going to come through the,
through this arm here,
up to a condenser,
and then drip into the tea leaves or whatever it is we want to extract,
held in a little cup inside here,
right?
And it's solid down here.
So this is just a cup,
but there's this funny snake,
like a tube that comes from the bottom of this up around,
down and back inside toward the flask.
So watch what happens when I,
for some,
uh,
liquid in here.
Okay?
So if you just pour water through a filter,
the water runs through very rapidly and doesn't have time to get,
become saturated.
So it's inefficient in two ways.
You've got to pour lots of water through and it doesn't get saturated on the way
through this way.
The,
the uh,
liquid,
you distilled up drips down in there,
sits with the stuff which has held,
remember in like a filter paper inside here,
right?
And you can see that the liquid,
let me see if I can get it so you can see it.
Did you see that the liquid went not only of course in here where it's with the
tea leaves,
but also through this too,
but not that far.
Okay.
So it's there and you can see the meniscus in the side arm.
Now what's going to happen when I pour a little more in it's drip,
drip,
drip.
Actually of course from a condenser,
it's getting right up to the top of that side arm.
What's going to happen.
So it's sitting there and becoming saturated and we go a little bit more,
what's it doing?
It siphons right?
But it sits there with the hot liquid until it gets to the top.
Then it draws all that off.
And then what happens?
More liquid boils up and comes in right and dissolves.
It's the same liquid.
Of course.
It's been distilled now.
All right.
So it comes on up and pretty soon it'll go a little quicker this time because
there's drops in the side arm
and it drains again.
So he use just a small amount of liquid over and over again.
And there are no moving parts right,
except boiling and the liquid.
So it's a really beautiful design of a clever apparatus if you want to make tea
efficiently.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now this is starting up
[inaudible]
and if I'm lucky,
it will have backed up my most recent work.
[inaudible]
it's got almost all of it.
That's good.
Let's see if it will come on.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
Thanks for bearing with me.
So a little more about,
uh,
the reactivity of,
of uh,
acid derivatives and then on to,
um,
to the sugar glucose proof,
one of the finest logical,
uh,
creations of the 19th century or ever,
first,
uh,
alkylation we s we started talking about this last time about the fact that an
[inaudible],
uh,
has charge partial charge both on the carbon and the oxygen.
So if you want to put an alk eal group on by an sn two type reaction problem.
Pardon me.
Oh,
thank you.
Yeah.
Uh,
one more time into the breach here.
John is on the,
uh,
on the button about whether I'm rehearsing the timings.
Okay.
So the question is whether you react with the carbon or the oxygen when you do
sn two,
when you react with methyl iodide,
now you could do a calculation and see,
uh,
where the homo is,
right?
The Homo looks like that.
It's a Pi orbital obviously with one,
a node,
a addition to the p orbitals that it's made of,
and that's big on the carbon.
So that would favor reaction on the carbon and the attack would be from the top
because it would come in on top of the p orbital of the carbon.
On the other hand,
if you look at the electrostatic potential,
the energy of Proton would have on the surface of this molecule when it's in
contact with it,
it's not the most favorable at the position to the homo.
It's minus 143 kilocalories per mole for a proton.
That would be there,
but it proton here is minus 170 kilocalories per mole.
And notice that it's the,
uh,
that it not only favors the oxygen,
but it's a sigma attack rather than a pie attack.
So you could imagine,
uh,
either of these positions attacking,
the methyl iodide.
Now,
in fact,
it turns out,
uh,
so that if at attack the carbon,
it would attack from the top is shown up here on the right out of the plane.
If it attack the oxygen,
it would attack in the plane.
Right?
And in fact,
it,
the major product is attack on carbon with methyl iodide and it's a negligible
amount of Oh,
a methylation.
But it's not always that way.
If you have a different,
uh,
a reagent to re,
different,
uh,
electrified to be attacked by the nucleophile,
for example,
silicon and displays chloride,
then it turns out to be just the other way.
It goes on oxygen,
85% yield and a negligible amount on the carbon.
So this is obviously a finely balanced thing and is not something that,
uh,
that you're going to be able to predict.
This is a part of lore which things go where right now if you use a strong an
ion to abstract the hydrogen adjacent to the Carbon Eel,
make the analyte right,
it's PKA is 12 units higher so that the equilibrium lies completely to form the
ina laid an eye on.
But one could imagine two different in a late and I and swear a protons been
taken from the right or from the left.
So there's another question about a possible reaction mixtures when you react
this with meth.
Elia died and if it's done with two equivalents of methyl iodide,
this was done by professor house at,
at the Mit.
Uh,
he found that 41% of the product,
uh,
alkylated on the ch two group and 9% alkylated on the group that had a methyl
group attached to it already.
But these aren't very good yields.
There was also 22% of recovered starting material.
So the question is,
where did the proton come from that went onto the recovered starting material.
Now this was done by adding a methyl iodide to the [inaudible] solution.
So there's just a little bit of methyl iodide there that reacts,
right and makes the key tone one of these two key tones down here.
Okay.
But then additional anhilate could abstract a proton for one of these and that
could become the new inculcate.
That could be where the proton came from to make the starting material,
right?
And in fact,
21% of the product has a second method beheaded and 6% of the product has three
new methyls added to the compound.
So it's a real dog's breakfast.
It's not the way you want to do this kind of thing,
right?
It's a very inefficient reaction.
There are other ways to do it.
Like for example,
use lithium,
uh,
die ice appropriately amid another really strong base.
This is done at very low temperature,
right?
And then the people who did this,
uh,
put in,
man goodies dichloride in a complex with lithium chloride again at minus 78.
And they made a different in a late and I,
and the one with manganese as the counter ion,
right?
And then they added this,
they added to this 1.3 equivalents of Benzel bromide and a different solvent.
The a methyl parole and methyl Perala don't,
and did that at room temperature.
Notice these are a lot,
this is lore.
This is a lot of fine description of exactly what solve what temperatures and so
on how you do it.
And under those conditions,
they were able to get 88% of this single product after distillation,
right?
So it's the pure stuff.
So it's a very high,
it's possible to do these accolations in it as a very yield reaction.
Now this is,
this is what's called an org sin prep.
There's when people,
when there's a very valuable,
a technique that people would like to be able to repeat,
it's uh,
it's submitted by the people who,
who,
uh,
who created it and checked by people at this,
at this organic syntheses operation,
and then they publish it.
And then you can believe that if you,
if you try it,
you'll be able to do it here because it's been checked.
So things that are an org send prep.
I've been very carefully done and all of these conditions are there,
but it would be very difficult ahead of time to figure out exactly all the
tricks you need to do to do it.
But you can look it up in organic synthesis.
Okay.
Uh,
Lda can also be used with carboxylic acids now.
so we want to make the analyte,
we want to extract that Red Proton.
Could you see any problem involved when you treat this with a strong base?
Hagen,
how's that?
What's,
what's the name of this product or this a starting material.
What kind of compound?
Right.
Why did they call it a carboxylic acid?
Great.
That's it.
Good up protons.
Is that the Proton it gives up?
Nope.
Gives that one up so you don't get the eternal light.
However,
this is a strong enough base that it's possible to pull off a second proton and
in fact get the analyte which lacks the negative charge that's supposed to be
there.
Okay,
and then that can react with an owl kio bromide at the more nuclear fillic,
the less stable and I and center and give a good yield of the of the alkylated
acid.
It's also even better of course to do die carbon eels,
which are more strongly acidic,
so you don't need these really strong acids,
so you use f oxide to do this.
It's,
it's a acidic enough that you could imagine using hydroxide,
but you don't use hydroxide to do this.
You use F oxide.
Can you guess why you useF oxide rather than hydroxide?
As always,
when you begin to get complicated reactions that this is not a very complicated
one.
There's several ways things can react and that this is not as in the last case
where you could pull off the wrong proton.
Right.
In this case,
the,
the base can not only pull off the Proton,
it can also act as a nucleophile.
And what would it do as a nucleophile
Jack?
That's right.
Hydroxide would attack the Ester,
right?
Oh,
h minus would come on.
Oh.
F oxide would come off and you would convert the Ester to an acid,
which would react with the strong base hydroxide.
And that would be the end of the line because you don't have this really super
strong base that could pull off two protons.
Okay.
So,
but if he was F and that attacks here,
who cares,
one or the other f oxides is going to come off and you're back where you started
again.
Right.
So then it's possible to wait until you pull that proton off.
Okay.
So that's called,
that compound is a Beta Quito.
Esther.
It's got a ketone in the second carbon from the ester group.
Okay.
So you make the anti ion reacted with,
uh,
with our,
with the leaving group,
and now you treat it with hydroxide,
right.
Because what you were really after was getting this acid with an r group on it.
Okay.
Uh,
but you don't use o h minus for that or you can use to Esther's to make the
thing acidic,
right.
Do exactly the same stuff and get the are on now with two acid groups and of
course it would be possible to do it a second time and put a second our group on
before you do the while.
It's still an ester before you add the hydroxide.
Okay.
So you can put out kill groups on these Beta Keto esters or melodic Esther
[inaudible] two with two Carbox late groups on it as melodic acid.
Okay.
Now you might want those compounds but much more,
uh,
or,
or we already in fact saw using Cyan OCD Kester you remember when we saw that we
used it?
Where are was this are with the leaving group?
It was the Mitsui Nobu procedure that we went through and showed that,
that that also then can can hydrolyze the,
the CNE group,
the night trial as well to give a second carboxyl group.
But mostly people aren't after this.
What thereafter is protonating those to give to give the Beta keto acid or the
melodic acid?
Why did I draw it that way?
Do you remember?
The h ports would be higher hydrogen
bonded to this oxygen,
but it can do more than that.
Remember from when we were talking about the Bitsa Nobu reaction,
we can do this right,
which results in decarboxylation when we heat it,
right?
And those are enols,
which of course can I summarize to the related ketone or on the second case into
an acid.
So the real purpose of using this Beta ketone Ester or the melodic Esther is to
put the,
our group on and then get these compounds.
So it's another way of getting to what was effectively that eda late,
except having the second Carbonie along made it easier to get,
you didn't need to use those really strong basis.
So you can,
you can synthesize and alkylated acid or an alkaline,
uh,
alkaline and acid or now collated ketone alco calculated in the Alpha position
by using these,
uh,
these dye carbon eel compounds.
The one on the top is called a Ceto with Siddique Esther synthesis.
Because,
because when you,
when this was still an ester here,
this was ch three,
uh,
Ceto acetic acid,
right?
So it goes by way of that to get the,
to get the Ketone,
or this one,
as we said,
was melodic Esther,
that we started with to get the acid.
Okay.
Notice that these are ways of adding to the art group two carbons,
right?
Either with the Ketone,
I mean,
there'd be another carbon of course,
if we're a ketone or two carbons here to make an acid.
And so when one's thinking about synthesis,
you try to think about how to put more carbons on.
Remember the aren't I stared procedure.
We,
we,
uh,
we talked about with dyes or methane or cyanide,
displacing chlorine from an art group or making a grin yard out of the alcohol
haylight and then add Nco to those all add one carbon to the chain.
But this thing adds two carbons at least or more in the,
in the case of this,
when you have an art group there and remember,
uh,
adding a nucleophile to open an EFP oxide also adds to carbon.
So they're there.
If you're in the business of organic synthesis,
these things become second nature.
I need to add this Aha,
I would use that reagent or that region or that region.
Okay.
Then one of the most important reactions is the aldol condensation.
Okay?
It was discovered first with acid Aldehyde,
which treated with base makes the,
uh,
makes the analyte right,
but it can react with itself.
All right?
And then when you protonate the o minus,
right,
you get this compound,
which in the case of acid Aldehyde,
this particular one with a methyl group here in the ch two group here has the
name Al Doll.
So this is called the aldol reaction.
It makes Aldol,
but you can make it with other groups here as well,
not just not just with a methyl group.
And so generically,
they're called Aldols,
the obviously the name is Aldehyde and alcohol Aldol,
but it's uh,
it can be dehydrated,
right?
Uh,
lose the Oah here at an age down here to give the unsaturated Aldehyde.
Now that's called a Beta hydro.
An aldol.
Aldol is a Beta hydroxy Aldehyde.
Okay.
And this is an Alpha Beta unsaturated Aldehyde.
So these are things that when you,
when you're looking at something you want to make and you see,
Aha,
it's a Beta hydroxy co carbon yield compound or it's an Alpha Beta unsaturated
carbonyl compound.
You think the aldol reaction,
if I assigned you a zillion problems to do that,
that would become second nature to you.
If it turns out that that's important to you,
you will do a lot of problems with it and it'll become second nature to you.
Now,
I've shown it here,
base catalyzed,
but it can be acid catalyzed as well.
And it'd be,
I would expect you to be able to figure out how the mechanism would work with
acid catalin isis.
Now the equilibrium for this as favorable because this isn't very crowded with h
h here and h is down here,
h here,
right?
But if you start with a ketone instead of an Aldehyde,
then the product is more crowded and less stable.
So if you start with acetone instead and make the an ion and tried to do this
reaction and make the Beta hydroxy ketone,
now you find that the equilibrium is unfavorable.
So you'd like to figure some trick if that's the compound you want,
that would allow you to get over there.
One way is not the start with the ketone,
but to start with the INA eight so you're much,
much higher and energy.
So these things we've talked about before about using really strong basis to
preform the anti on,
those are ways to do this.
But if you want to deal just with hydroxide,
there's a way to do it.
Now,
we already went through the demonstration of showing how you make tea by pouring
hot water through a tea bag in a funnel,
but a much more efficient ways to use this sock slit extractor.
So the extractor looks like this,
you boil liquid down below and you condense it up above and it drips down into a
paper cup that's holding the tea or whatever it is,
and it begins to rise up.
And when it gets up to the top and finally goes over the top,
it drains down and then the whole cycle starts over again.
Right?
So that's a much more efficient way to do extract to make tea.
But it's also a way to make aldol because of what you put in the cup.
So the liquid you're going to use is acetone.
Okay.
The liquid is acetone,
so it's distilling up,
sitting there for awhile and then draining back and distilling up again right
now required.
Remember that it takes a catalyst
to make the aldol right.
A base as what we've shown here.
So suppose you had a base that was only in the cup,
right?
Then the acetone will come and sit in the cup and reach equilibrium if it's
sitting there for awhile with the base,
which has just a little bit of the alcohol in it because the equilibrium lies to
the left,
right?
But then it drains down into the pot where there's no base,
so it can't go back again.
But the dimer,
of course,
much heavier than the starting material,
so it doesn't still,
the acetone goes back up,
drips through again,
makes it a little bit more and drains in up a little more,
a little more,
a little more.
So all you have to do is put in that cup up above a base,
which is not soluble in acetone,
right?
So barium hydroxide is such a thing.
So that's a really fancy way to make,
uh,
an Aldo.
When it was unfavorable,
he was in a sock slit extractor.
Okay.
Now it's possible to do a cross aldol condensation where you do,
where the [inaudible] comes from.
One carbon eel compound and the carbon eel that gets attacked comes from another
one in particular.
Suppose you start with what's called a set o fa known that methyl phenol ketone
make.
It's an ion and at attacks,
if it were to attack itself with methyl and fennel,
the equilibrium would be very unfavorable.
It'd be way too crowded.
Right?
But if you put in there,
so this one won't work,
that's an unfavorable equilibrium.
But suppose instead you use Benzaldehyde.
Right now it's not hindered because it's an Aldehyde.
So you could make the product with benzene here,
Benzine here,
and a chair by this crossed two different reagents.
This one and this one aldol condensation.
Now it's clear that this one is not going to react with itself with its own
ketone because the product will be too hindered.
But why won't the INA late of that react with itself?
It'd be much less hindered.
This is a trick question.
Why doesn't the INA late of this carbon eel compound react with the,
with the Aldehyde Ella,
what would the ELA to later this be?
How do you make an analyte?
Where do you take the h from?
From the carbon.
It's adjacent to the Carbondale,
right?
So that the Pi Star,
the Carbondale will stabilize the an ion.
So what,
what's the story here?
There isn't any,
the benzene ring,
there's no hydrogen on that carbon,
right?
So this can't form an Eataly and this can't react with itself.
So they'll,
so they cross over without complication,
right?
So that one can't form a needle eight and you can then lose water to make the
Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone.
Now I'll just uh,
uh,
go through this,
which I did on the board last year and took a picture of,
so this is the compound we just made on the previous slide,
right?
It's an Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone and it undergoes what's called conjugate
edition.
That is you expect a nucleophile to act to react with the carbon eel carbon,
the Pi Star.
But if you have a situation like this,
cyanide could react not only there,
but also here.
And if it reacts here and then you put on a proton on the,
Oh,
you could put,
you have the Adelaide and I and once the cyanide is attacked up at the top left
here,
right?
So there's a charge here,
charge here.
So you could put the Proton,
either place,
the more stable place to put the Proton is down here.
So you have a carbon oxygen double bond rather than to put it on the oxygen.
So you have an eternal,
we know that carbon steels are more stable than enols.
So this is the product you get from that.
And sometimes it's,
I think it's safest to call it conjugate addition because you add to a double
bond that cyanide would not normally add to remember alkanes are usually
attacked by electrifying,
not nuclear files.
But this one is special because adding here you get,
you generate a stable and I on the inhalation,
okay,
so that's called conjugate edition or sometimes it's called one four edition.
So here's the one,
two,
three,
four position.
You add a hydrogen there and cyanide here.
That would be one for addition to this thing.
The product of course would be an email late,
but the analyte it will become a ketone.
So that's just the name that's given this,
uh,
one four edition.
But conjugate I think is better.
Okay.
Now if you react with the Grin Yar reagent,
fennel,
magnesium bromide,
it does the same thing.
Cyanide does,
it undergoes conjugate addition and you get a 96% yield of this.
Uh,
and if you use a copper,
it turns out that that sometimes helps to get conjugate edition if you had it.
Okay.
But if he use instead of fennel,
magnesium,
bromide,
fennel,
lithium,
then it doesn't do the one for or the conjugate addition.
It adds as you would naively of expected to the carbon eel group.
Right.
So obviously there's a lot of subtlety involved here and a lot of Lore,
I would certainly not have expected you to know.
I,
uh,
I would expect you to know that you could add here and having thought about it a
little bit,
I would expect you to think that you could add here,
but as to which way it goes and why a grin you,
our reagent goes here and why copper helps it or while fennel lithium goes here
that I wouldn't expect you to know.
Okay.
That's what comes,
that's the lore that comes from being in the business awhile.
But when you've been around,
you know what to do,
you know,
to throw copper in if you,
if this is the kind of product you want.
Okay.
And the same kind of thing happens with,
with hydride edition.
So if you have this a cyclohexene own and reduce it with lithium aluminum
hydride the hydride does what you expect it to do.
It adds to the carbon and the carbon eel and you get this unsaturated alcohol
cyclohexene old 97% yield,
right?
But if you use a different source of hydride,
the Bh four minus instead of alh four minus,
then you get only a 59% yield of this product and you get 41% the rest of it is
the material that's lost the double bond.
So the double bond has been reduced to now VH four BH three remember ads,
the double bonds,
but BH four minus doesn't.
And when v h three adds,
it adds an age and also the Boron and that's the way you get an alcohol.
I remember the hydro voracious oxidation,
right?
Good Bh four minus is different.
It doesn't react with double bonds.
And if you take this material and react it with Bh Sodium borohydride,
it doesn't do that.
So that's not where this came from.
Where it came from was having the first edition be conjugate.
So hydride added to this position,
the end of the double bond that's conjugated with the carbon eel as in the top
left there,
right?
That made this anal eight right,
which then got protonated in this position to give them the ketone instead of
the eternal.
Okay.
And now that carbon eel can be reduced by borough hydride the same way this one
could at the beginning and now you get the 41% of that.
So you must initially have gotten almost equal amounts of reduction of the
carbonyl group directly by one,
two edition and,
and conjugate addition,
41% of conjugate edition,
which then led to that.
So again,
this is lore and if we drilled you on that,
you would know something,
you would be able to have quick recall of it.
Uh,
having seen it,
I expect you to recognize things like that,
but I don't expect you to know all the details.
In fact,
I think no one knows all the details.
This is all sensitive to exact,
you know,
what temperature exactly what salsa use,
what solvent and so on.
So it's a complicated thing or adding the copper.
Okay.
Now a very interesting reaction is called the Robinson annulation.
Annulation means making your ring.
And this was invented in 1935 and here's the beginning of the paper where it was
invented by wraps and a graduate student,
and Sir Robert Robinson,
who got the Nobel prize for synthetic organic chemistry.
So it's experiments on the census of substance substances related to steer
roles.
Should I remember steroid?
These hormones are six membered ring six membered ring six membered ring five
membered ring with various lettuce hanging around it,
right?
So there are lots of these different things.
And the 1930s was the golden age,
and that through the 1950s and sixties was the golden age of steroid chemistry.
And remember that was the basis on which con formational analysis was invented
in,
in 1958 Barton who was working in this field started looking at which side axial
equatorial on all that.
That was all done in the context of steroids,
right?
But what Robinson says here is the methods for synthesis of one five Dy.
Ketones.
So here's the ketone one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
So a one five dy.
Ketone.
Okay.
Methods for sentences,
a one five dy.
Ketones have been explored in this laboratory for two reasons.
One,
it was thought that pinnacles,
such as one might furnish the characteristic angled methyl ketone group to of
estrogen.
So estrogen is a,
is a female hormone,
right?
And it has that five membered ring up in the top right,
has this as a ketone there,
and a methyl,
what's called an angular methyl group adjacent to it.
So how are you going to synthesize that?
So he thought that that could come from this via a pinnacle rearrangement.
We talked about the pinnacle rearrangement.
Remember,
what's going to happen is you,
you would protonate here,
lose water,
cad ion meth,
I'd shift,
right?
So now you've got the methyl there from this five membered ring.
So,
uh,
so you need that compound if you want to be able to make it that way.
Where do you get a pinnacle?
You get it from pinnacle reduction,
right?
So you would get it from this forming the bond across there.
And we talked about the pinnacle reduction where you put an electron on here,
an electron on here,
the two free radicals couple,
and then you have oh minus cc bond oh minus,
right?
And then they get protonated to give the pinnacle.
Okay?
So that would be the pinnacle reduction.
So that was what he was hoping as a way to try to make this five membered ring
with that methyl group,
which is hard to put in there otherwise.
Okay?
Uh,
buy in Trump in trouble.
I Cuellar change,
which we would now call a rearrangement.
And the second reason was the dye ketones themselves.
Three might be dehydrated with the formation of cyclohexene owns.
So you can make a six membered ring with a double bond carbon eel.
Now what do you notice about that double bond?
How he says you might be able to go from here to here.
So this might,
these double bar double shafted arrows are thinking backwards.
It's called Retro Synthesis.
What could something come from right?
The older,
but Arrow will be this going into this.
But when you see this,
you think of this,
why,
when you see this functional group,
do you think of this dye ketone?
You look at that functional group and what would you call it?
Can you give a name to that?
Hey,
can you think of any names for functional groups there?
What's,
what's this functional group to c Double Bondo.
He told me,
and this one
an Lpn,
so you could call it an ene own right,
but then you wouldn't know where the IAN is.
So you have to say where are the Ian is relative to the Ketone to get that
functional group to know that their conjugated.
So it's so the,
if you start with the ketone,
it's the Alpha and the Beta position.
So it's an Alpha Beta unsaturated ketone.
And there's another name for Alpha Beta unsaturated ketones.
They're the dehydration product of Aldols,
right?
So the aldol reaction,
where you make an an eye on here,
it attacks that carbon deal to make ooh.
And then you dehydrate it.
He says dehydrated here,
lose the OAH and an h here to make the double bond.
So that's the reaction we just talked about.
The aldol reaction.
Uh Okay.
So,
so then you need this compound,
right?
You need that dye ketone if you're going to make it that way.
And how will you make it?
You'll make it by forming the red bond,
attacking this double bond here.
What kind of car,
what kind of reactions that Luke,
you've got an idea.
Okay.
If you made an anti in here,
right?
That would be an INA laid a n I n pulled an h off there.
Okay.
So you could make the anti in here and then you want to attack a ketone.
Right?
So you'd think of making a bond from here to here.
But this is making the bond from here to here.
Did you ever see anything like that?
About eight minutes ago we talked about conjugate edition,
right addition to the double bond adjacent to the carbon eel,
which cause,
cause if the ad I and attacks here,
then you have a minus charge on this carbon adjacent to the Carbon Neil.
It's an anal eight and I am,
so this is an example of conjugate addition.
So what you would need then,
this would be conjugate addition to this key tone.
And that ketone before you make the red bond is methyl and a c double bond.
C H two vinyl.
So that's methyl vinyl ketone,
right,
which is a very important reagent for making these six membered ring compounds.
Okay?
So that's the,
so this,
the idea of making this ring compound by way of methyl vinyl ketone attacking a
ketone is called the,
uh,
Robinson annulation procedure.
The way of forming a ring.
Okay,
so a base,
uh,
to make the anhilate and then methyl vinyl ketone.
So it takes this into two six membered rings adjacent to one another with the
carbon eel down here,
which is just like what's in the bottom left hand corner of these steroids.
Six membered ring with an oxygen pointed down that way,
and another six membered ring.
So the,
the Robinson annual Asian is just the ticket for forming this thing and they
often have a methyl group in that position,
right?
So you'll see these are the four carbons that become these four part,
the,
these four carbons in the product.
So you to do that,
you'd need an analyst at this position doing a conjugate addition to attack
here.
So this carbon becomes that carbon.
Then you form an anti in here at that position,
right?
And enal eight it is right?
And beyond the carbon eel,
there's one more methyl group.
This one.
Okay.
But once you've got that,
then once you've got the methyl group here and still a ketone here,
right?
Then you can have the anti on of that methyl group,
the analyte attack,
the carbon eel and aldol reaction dehydrate.
And you've got this thing.
So that all happens at once when you use methyl vinyl ketone and the Ketone,
except you have to be sure that you've got the right anti on here,
that the anti on is the,
at that position,
the,
you know,
late that you're starting with and not at that position.
And we'll address that on Friday.
How you make sure you've got the right [inaudible].
Okay.
And uh,
Woodward,
because on,
on Friday we'll be talking about Woodward's synthesis of the steroids,
cortisone,
where he used Robinson's of method.
We showed this picture before last semester and they're not acknowledging one
another's presence here.
They both were uh,
quite,
uh,
each of them.
I'm sure it was quite confident that he was the most important organic chemists
to the 20th century.
And here on,
on the,
what's,
what's especially interesting is here you see the double bonds not drawn,
but this is that cyclohexene on the product from a Robinson annulation.
Okay.
Then there's one called the Clayson condensation or climbs and condensation,
which is now an Ester,
but it's all these are the same.
You make an eda late and you react here with itself.
So in fact,
when I made slides,
I could use exactly the same slide and just plug in one group different each
time.
So as you look at these,
you'll be able to organize them clearly in your mind.
So here now is an Ester.
Why do we use our o minus rather than hydroxide
as we don't want to make the acid right?
We want to keep the ester.
Okay,
so we have our own minus,
we,
we talked about that before,
make the Ino eight and now this one comes over and gets attacked.
So it starts like the same way on Haldol does if the starting material,
we're an Aldehyde,
right?
Or a ketone.
But it's different because you have a leaving group on here.
So when it comes back in,
that leaving group can leave.
So instead of getting an alcohol from the group that gets attacked,
you get a carbonyl group.
Okay?
So it's a Beta Quito,
Esther instead of Beta hydroxy ketone Beta Hydroxy Aldehyde.
That's the aldol reaction.
It's a Beta Quito,
Esther,
because you had a leaving group.
So it's not an alcohol right now,
again,
this equilibrium is unfavorable if you have a,
if you have more complicated groups on here,
right?
But it's,
at first it looked like the owl coc side was catalytic.
We used that here to,
uh,
to,
make the EDA late.
But then we got it back again here.
So it looks like a catalyst that just cycles around and around.
You don't need very much of it.
But this Beta Quito,
Esther,
is quite acidic,
so it actually eats up the lie.
Lie as in supine suffocation that we talked about last time.
Okay,
then that's good because the equilibrium here might have been unfavorable,
but once you do this very exothermic reaction taking off one of those hydrogens,
then the reaction is favorable again.
Okay,
so now here's,
here's nature's version of the clays and condensation,
okay?
They use the special Esther instead of oxygen.
It's got sulfur here,
but it does exactly the same thing.
It makes the anti and at attacks you get a Beta Quito,
Esther,
it's a thioester and co Aa is coenzyme a.
So it's a special art group that's attached to the,
to make it an Esther if you're interested.
That's the our group,
right?
There's the sh that's going to be that thing there.
Right?
But that will be for another day.
Okay,
so it,
how do they,
how does nature get around the fact that this equilibrium is unfavorable,
that it would come back?
It puts an extra co two in.
So instead of starting with this being ch three,
it starts with an extra CO2 group on it here.
So it's a dike die,
carbonyl compound,
easier to form the,
the uh,
anti.
And now you might think if that's a negative charge,
it's gonna be hard to form the anti on.
But in the enzyme where it's held,
this one is not ionized.
I'm not sure exactly how it's tied up,
but anyhow,
it helps make this one the city,
Kevin,
the carbon eel next door,
and then you get this product.
So it's Maaleh Neil not asset deal.
Right?
And then the equilibrium is driven by losing the co two.
Okay.
So that's how nature does Clayson condensations why?
Because it wants to store energy,
right?
So notice it's put this asset,
he'll group on the original acid or Esther,
it's for this new bond,
right where it had the word attacked and had a leaving group.
Okay.
So then nature reduces it using the reducing agent and a d h that we talked
about.
Okay.
So it becomes an alcohol and then it dehydrates,
it's a Beta hydroxy carbonyl compound,
just like aldols at dehydrates.
And then it gets reduced again to put h two in here.
So we have this product we started,
uh,
with,
with having just one methyl group,
but just two carbons here and now we have one,
two,
three,
four carbons there.
And notice what you can do.
You can take this Esther and plug it in up above
and put another two carbons on when you come around to get this right.
And you can plug it in,
put another two carbons,
another two carbons.
So you could make a long chain of carbons,
ca of reduced carbons ending in an acid or an ester to start with.
So,
so these are fatty acids.
That's how you store the energy fueled a burn is these successive ch two groups
that can be oxidized,
but the fatty acids that occur in nature are all even numbers of carbon,
not odd numbers because it makes them this way and always adds two carbons at a
time to the chain.
Okay.
Now
I want to say just two words now about,
or more than two,
but not many,
more than two about,
uh,
carbohydrates.
So carbohydrate was named early on.
I've,
I've got to look it up and find out.
It must've been a in the early 19th century once they could analyze them and see
they were c h two o taken in times.
So carbohydrate,
a hydrate of carbon.
Right now,
Cooper in 1858 had the idea of Tetra Valence.
And once you had that,
a number of sugars had been,
had been observed,
but no one had any idea what structure was.
So that was hard to talk about them,
right?
You could talk about some of their properties,
but not obviously about their structure.
So if you have a carbohydrate,
Cooper would put two more bonds on the carbon.
So you can make a chain of these,
say six,
right?
But this is unsatisfactorily.
You've got to do something with those two,
those two bonds on the end,
right?
You could make a carbon ring,
a six membered ring.
Cyclohexane with Oah is all around,
but that's not what what you do.
Uh,
what Cooper did in his very first paper,
you remember about structure,
he gave a structure for glucose.
And the structure he gave was this,
what did he do with the extra bonds?
How did he modify this chain in order to get his structure?
Okay,
well of course,
remember there they're double oxygen's,
where in fact there should be a single oxygen.
That's because of the uh,
but what else?
Yeah,
he took water and put h on one end and o h on the other.
Right.
And in fact you can do that.
This is a gem dial.
That's an Aldehyde that's been hydrated.
Okay.
That's one way to do it.
Another way to do it is to take a,
this is what,
this is what got lost when my computer crashed.
So this one notice took,
took the Hoh that was here,
took the H's away,
put one h up here,
the other h down there.
And this one took the two H's away from this one,
but one h up there,
the other h down there.
Okay.
So,
um,
so these then are sugars,
but who knows which one is which.
Okay.
Oh,
this is,
sorry,
that was [inaudible] and this is a page from van Hoff's.
That was 1858.
1874.
Stereochemistry.
Right.
What makes things optically active?
Uh,
Van Hoffen is 1874.
Paper says these compounds are optically active.
Glucose,
love,
yellows,
lactose,
mannitol.
So this,
the,
this is it because he's got four different things on this carbon,
the four that are in the middle of the chain,
right?
Or Mannitol,
the one where you've added,
uh,
h to each end of the Aldehyde,
right?
That's the,
uh,
then you still have these things or derivatives of mannitol or the dye acid
where you have an acid at each end of the chain.
All these things were optically active,
right?
That's part of his,
so there were a number of sugars known,
uh,
by that time.
But the really fine work began to be done in the 1880s by Heinrich Iliani and
Emile Fisher.
And that will be a treat for next time.